amy is with us in Seattle hi Amy welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave I'm so
thrilled to talk to you my husband
brought you up on our very first date so
you've literally been a part of our
relationship from the beginning your
husband might be a nerd oh my gosh oh
that's funny I love it how can I help
today my question is about planning
travel with friends my friend and her
husband have asked if we would like to
plan a fun weekend just the four of us
and we live on opposite sides of the
country so we'd probably meet somewhere
in the middle my husband and I are
debt-free except for the mortgage and we
follow your steps and budget monthly
annually they still have a significant
amount of debt and while I know they're
working to paid off it doesn't appear
like they're following a really strict
plan we want to spend time with them but
we also don't want to enable poor
financial choices that might keep them
in debt so I was curious what you would
do in this situation well okay the
conversation was not hey these people
are trying to get out of debt and you
called them up and tempted them and you
pulled them all that you know they were
on the wagon and you pulled them off the
wagon that's not what yeah ok MSDSs
people this is people that on their own
are doing whatever they want to do and
they included you ok so my rule is if
people if I think someone the closer I
am to someone relationally the more I am
to the more I'm apt to initiate
something that needs to be corrected
okay oh but I've got a friend of mine
that that's probably worth um he's
probably worth 1012 million dollars he's
fairly wealthy all right but he still
uses his credit card we're pretty good
friends but he knows where I stand on
that you know and we go out to dinner
and um the other day he picked up my
dinner and with a credit card I'm not
saying anything about that he can buy my
dinner it's his choice I think it's
stupid I carry a debit card I don't
in credit cards you know that but I'm
not going to go oh no you know you know
run run get all up in this stuff right
but now if it's if it's somebody that
you know is completely being
irresponsible like they're you know
they're they can't pay their light bill
they're you know their children are not
got clothing because they're traveling I
mean they're just out of control
yeah I wouldn't want to participate at
that level but I think this is just
somebody that's not got their act
together and maybe you spending time
with them that week would be the first
time they actually do understand what
they're supposed to do maybe they would
ask about what you're doing and maybe
that would help them get more intense
when they went home you know so I would
do the trip is what I'm trying to say I
don't think these I don't think these
people are like your best friends in the
world and like you would feel like you
had harmed them somehow these are their
friends that just don't do stuff the way
you do it but like another friend of
mine bought it you know he came up the
drove his new car up to show it to me
the dainty least it well I'm not gonna
spend the whole time talking about how
stupid his leasing that car is I just he
didn't bring him didn't ask my advice
and I'm freaking Dave Ramsey you know I
mean he didn't ask my advice he just
drove his car up there want me to brag
on his cars that's what I did i bragged
on his car man it's a nice car it's a
great car I'm glad you got that car and
I didn't go well you know you're really
being irresponsible leasing it which he
is he's being here he's should have done
that but I didn't bring that up I just
enjoy the car with him and then whatever
but again if it was my closest friend in
the world probably before he did that he
would have said something to me you know
but this guy's just a friend does that
make sense okay okay he is my best
friend though okay well I mean you have
like rings of things in your life and
the people that are in your closest ring
in this bull's eye of the ring right are
the ones that you you've really got your
arm around their shoulder so it's pretty
easy to pop them in the back of the head
you know so but they if she's that close
to you she knows what y'all are doing
right well okay and so you've already
made your statement to her with your
life and inspire
of that they want to do this trip right
oh yeah you're not going to you're not
going to convince her of doing anything
by not doing the trip you're not going
to help her with she's not going to
listen to you because you didn't do the
trip she might listen to you if you did
the trip and maybe the next time it
comes up you just go you know we did the
other one but we just feel like we're
endorsing this and we don't want to
endorse it anymore
because we think what we think you guys
are borderline irresponsible until you
get your act together but you may you
may lose a degree of the friendship when
you do that you know that well so I'm
probably doing this one out you got to
gauge it out as to how close you are and
you know and what you can pull off here
but what I'm always trying to think of
is how can I have the most influence in
their life and have I earned the right
with the depth of my relationship to get
all up in their business you know and
that's but generally the way I know that
is somebody asks now you guys on the
radio you call you ask and so you ask
for it so I'm going to give it to you
right you're going to give you the
answer and we'll get on your step on
your toes or whatever I need to do to
help you but that's what the show is
about it's a different situation but if
a friend or a relative asks I won't be
all in there I'm going to help them but
those are convinced against their will
or of the same opinion still my granny
used to say and I've always remembered
that one that's me trying to convince
somebody do something that isn't gonna
do it they're just not going to I just
don't believe the way I believe I got a
friend that's a copper actor and he
doesn't need anything that's not a
sprout of some kind you know and I'm a
carnivore you know I eat like meat and
he thinks I'm going to die well I am
someday but it's probably not from a
hamburger
so in our just I'm not as intense about
my health as he is and I don't view it
the way he views it but we can still be
friends but if every time I go out he's
thrashing me about what I'm eating then
I don't want to go out with a guy
anymore
you know cuz I'm going to eat a
hamburger shut up you want to be a vegan
or a vegan or whatever it is you're
going to be that's fine I'm a carnivore
that's cool I'm not gonna pick on you
about you know about the fact that you
don't really have any red blood cells
I'm not gonna pick on you about that but
you know but it's fine
my buddy Seth Godin is a he know
any meat or whatever you know he's like
a he's not full-on vegetarian when he
caught one ate only I don't know I can't
remember anyway I can't keep up with all
the names people have for themselves but
Seth you know he eats real healthy he's
a little skinny guy and you know he
probably thinks I'm kind of some kind of
like Fred Flintstone character with a
big big pork chop on my plate or
something but you know we just we're not
going to argue about he and our friends
you know he's fine with that and I'm
fine I guess he's fine with me being a
carnivore I hope he is cuz I am I'm
probably going to continue to be like
here in the next few minutes probably so
that's that's the way I look at this
stuff I mean I don't know if it's helped
I feel like I'm babbling but you know
there's this whole thing about
accountability that came up particularly
in the Christian world several years ago
I start a pursed time I saw it big time
was back around Promise Keepers
everybody needs accountability or by any
scanner ability yeah you need
accountability but the only way someone
is accountable in to you in your life is
that you've earned the right to speak
into their life by loving them well and
by having a relationship with them now
in your case Amy this is your good
friend you have earned that right I'm
not questioning that but then how can
you be the most effective at assisting
them you may never be you may be like my
friend the contractor he's never going
to talk me out of eating beef it's not
going to happen
I will die at 96 years old from my beef
eating you know so it's just not going
to happen I'm not mad about it but he
and I if all he brings up is that all
the time so you can earn the right to
get so far and then at a certain point
you accept people for where they are and
you move on and that includes this
financial stuff and so I don't beat
family members up why here and do brings
is boom when you don't do this stuff
most of them don't by the way most of
you that listen to this show or a whole
lot more stringent to what we teach than
my own family is not to talk about my
kids but I'm talking about my extended
family and so it's okay still love them
there's no family you know
still part of the thing so that's the
way I do it Amy just a little more kick
back and I'm not going to fret about
other people's business quite so much
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
Oh